back with another episode of hero ball  and we're going to check out some of my  favorite little tidbits that you  probably didn't catch let's do it I  think most of you guys will recognize  this one but Luca does the meme  um you know where he looked up at Devin  Booker little smile he's the cutest and  as we see here Joker hits uh Luke in the  back just like he did the Morris twin  pretty sure he got teed up boom we have  Devin Booker complaining about being  doubled are we really doubling in open  combat you wouldn't think NBA players  complain about getting double teamed but  he did hey bro we're not done with an  open gym bro and we also have Giannis  um taking forever the free-through line  here we go  almost ready  this one's not just 10 seconds he  clearly goes way over  this is only episode two keep tuned into  hero ball baby let's go